well as you could see I have sustained a
serious life-threatening injury that's
what happened over the weekend if you're
listening on itunes there's a bandaid on
my finger it's what I'm referring to
it's kind of a funny story actually I
was so my wife was out of the house on
on Saturday and she was going to meet a
friend who would it was and come into
town and I decided while she was out of
town that I was going to spend my time
trying to whittle an arrow out of a
stick that I found in the backyard why
because because why not
and also because my son had gotten a bow
and arrow set for for Christmas but the
arrows were kind of cheap and a few of
them are broken already so I said to him
you know what I'm gonna Whittle you I'll
make you an arrow that's what I'll do
all right your old man's gonna show you
how to make an arrow and so he was very
excited by that also my my son's going
through kind of this Elizabeth Warren
phase where he's obsessed with with
Indians and he he's learning about
Indians reading about them he has a
teepee that he plays in and so I thought
it'd be cool to show him how Indians
would make arrows I assume that this is
how they did it so anyway the problem
was that I couldn't find my pocket knife
so I texted my wife and said where's my
pocket knife I want to whittle an arrow
and I guess it shows it tells you
something that my wife didn't really
question that at all she didn't have any
questions she just she just told me
where where she put it and I know you
might say what kind of a man has to text
his wife about where his pocket knife is
it should just be in his pocket but I
text my wife to find that where you know
it's just a reflex any time I'm looking
for anything I'll just text her I was I
texted her where's the refrigerator the
other day it's just it's a reflex now
it's just what I do so I text her wait
where's the pocket knive she told me I
said I'm gonna widdle an arrow she
didn't really have any reaction to that
oddly enough and then about 90 seconds
into the whittling process I took a nice
little chunk out of my finger it went
pretty deep and the blood was flowing
pretty good and then I didn't know where
the band-aids or the hydrogen peroxide
is so I had a tech store where it where
are the band-aids and the hydrogen
peroxide so it's kind of a it's sort of
a funny you know
because from her perspective I text
where's my pocketknife and then like 90
seconds later hey by the way unrelated
where the band-aids and the hydrogen
peroxide just so you know though that my
kids were not traumatized by the sight
of me bleeding all over the place and I
know that because while I was in the
process of bleeding and fumbling around
for band-aids
my son comes up to me and asks for a
snack so that just to show you how
concerned he was anyway um the Golden
Globes were yesterday I they the Golden
Globes were held yesterday I haven't
seen the ratings yet for the show but I
continue to doubt whether any human has
ever actually sat down to watch an
entire award show on television I just I
can't I refuse to believe that anyone
would do that to themselves willingly of
all the ways to spend an evening you
could read a book you could play a board
game you could will Whittle an arrow you
could cut off your finger so many things
you could do that would be better than
sitting there for seven hours watching
rich people congratulate themselves I
just I don't believe that anyone is ever
I don't think that any awards show has
ever been watched on TV by anyone that's
my theory but there was an awards show
yesterday the Golden Globes and it seems
that one thing happened there that's
worth mentioning because it was a moment
of incredible though unintentional
honesty
Christian Bale won the Golden Globe for
his performance as Dick Cheney in the
movie Vice I haven't seen the movie I've
heard that it's absurdly openly biased
not surprising about you know that's not
very surprising basically it's just an
undisguised hit piece against Cheney and
the Bush administration it makes no
attempt at all to appear that it's
anything other than hit these and here's
the thing about that I don't personally
I don't have a problem with movies that
mock politicians as I say all the time
politicians should be mocked mocking
politicians is it's an American pastime
as an American tradition
it's about the most American thing you
could ever do is insult one of our
politicians they should all be insulted
just just on principle it's a wonderful
thing to do the problem though is that
Hollywood would never make a vice-like
movie about say Bill Clinton it would
never ever put something so naked ly
scornful and contemptuous out there
about a Democrat politician it would
just never do that that's the problem
the problem is how one-sided it is my my
dream my vision would be a situation
where there are these kinds of movies
coming out every year tons of them about
Republicans and Democrats where we're
just constantly mocking and making fun
of these people it's it's it's what
Thomas Jefferson would have wanted okay
now the closest thing that I think
Democrats have done or Hollywood has
done the same thing the closest thing
Hollywood has done about Democrats would
be the movie Chappaquiddick about the
time when Ted Kennedy drowned a woman
but then I saw that movie it's a very
good movie but the difference is that
they waited 50 years to tell that story
and the movie which again was a good
movie worth watching but it's also it's
a mature movie okay it's not agitprop
it's not a it's not a cartoon like vice
and so the principal players all come
across about as sympathetically as
possible given the circumstances given
that it's a movie about a woman drowning
and then people trying to cover it up
and trying to you know figure a way to
wiggle out of it legally and politically
given all of that the principle players
come across about as sympathetically as
possible the movie isn't trying to paint
anyone as just straightforwardly evil
those kinds of movies are always about
Republicans always a Democrat will never
be the target of a movie like that so
in any case christian bale one and then
he gets up there
to accept his award and as kind of a
nice change of pace because usually or
often anyway you'll see these people go
up and they'll thank god for helping
them to produce whatever piece of filth
are being awarded for but in this case
christian bale proceeded to thank satan
during his acceptance speech and i think
it's the first time i don't know but i'm
pretty sure it's the first time you know
how they would award ceremony that satan
has been explicitly thanked for helping
whatever achievement now his his
thanking of satan was meant to be
tongue-in-cheek he was saying that satan
helped him helped to inspire him to play
dick cheney so it was meant to be an
insult of dick cheney obviously but it
was unintentionally I think the most
honest moment in the history of award
shows and really I would prefer I would
prefer this I would prefer it if most of
these people went up there and just
thanked Satan rather than thanking God
for whatever degrading nonsense
they produced because Satan is glorified
by Hollywood much more than God is
glorified and I think Satan's influence
is far more evidence in most of what
Hollywood comes out with than is God's
influence so yes thank Satan Satan
deserves most of the credit after all I
think Christian Bale had that right so
that was a I think in the end that was a
revealing honest moment and and we
should all be thankful for it speaking
of award shows you've heard obviously
that Kevin Hart had to resign from his
Oscars hosting gig after the outrage
mobs descended on him for some
supposedly homophobic jokes that he made
years ago on Twitter and in one of his
stand-up acts well Hart appeared on
Ellen this past Friday and Ellen
obviously
a lesbian woman and she expressed her
support for Kevin Hart and asked him to
rescind his resignation and to host the
Oscars again she said that she talked to
the the Oscars people and they said that
they would still like to have Kevin Hart
host even though they threw him under
the bus and all that so she said that
she thinks Kevin Hart's a great guy a
phenomenal talent he's already
apologized for the jokes and he
shouldn't need to keep apologizing and
we all we should all just move on that
was her point now I'm not much of a fan
of Ellen DeGeneres I don't I'm not I
don't really have an opinion about her
one way or another I don't watch the
show but I thought it was a it was a
good moment and I thought it was great
that she kind of stood up to defend Hart
against the the rage mobs and it was
good that she did it as a lesbian woman
because you would think according to the
rules of identity politics that should
short of that should sort of shut down
the rage mobs now that because she has
the credibility to stand up and make
this point well the left apparently did
not agree they did not like that Ellen
had betrayed them by refusing to join
with them and grab a pitchfork and all
of that so Ellen was attacked for
defending Kevin Hart I'll give you just
one example of the responses that she
received there was an editorial that
made the rounds over the weekend and the
editorial had this title who died and
made Ellen DeGeneres the gay Pope the
article by someone named drew Goines
says in part kindness doesn't mean
forgiving people who've done bad things
without being sure they understand what
happened and are committed to making
things right DeGeneres is unilateral
dispensation to Hart on behalf of the
LGBTQ community and her kneecapping of
hearts critics truncates that process
that's bad for all the LGBTQ people she
claims to represent and it's bad for
Hart who gets to skip over the part of
the process where he becomes a better
more
pathetic person Hart made a half-hearted
apology where he would he announced that
he was stepping down his host but he
hasn't made any clear amends to LGBTQ
people and he certainly doesn't seem to
have atoned for his words how can he so
long as he views the criticism of his
past words as quote slander on my name
more important even if Hart had more
fully repented his sins are not
DeGeneres's to forgive well then first
of all who's who is the person who's
allowed to forgive him if Ellen
DeGeneres can't but think about the
words that are being used here repent
dispensation make amends atone who
exactly is the one claiming to be Pope I
mean what sort of egomaniac demands
atonement rather than simply accepting
the apology atonement atone what what is
that what do you what is he supposed to
do according to you drew goings and the
rest of the people on the Left who are
upset that Ellen DeGeneres dare accept
an apology from Kevin Hart what is he
supposed to do to atone himself does he
need to go out into the wilderness for
for 40 days and fast doesn't need to
walk down the street you know in I mean
begging forgiveness what does he need it
doesn't need to run through some kind of
gauntlet what what do you need him to do
if somebody hurts your feelings if
someone says something that hurts your
feelings and they apologize that's
supposed to be the end of it you're not
suppose
to say well you haven't fully repented
atone for your sins atone well what kind
of person says that atone I mean who do
you think you are
and this again is the incredible
arrogance that you often find on the
militant gay left this insistence that
everybody bow before them and kiss their
feet
it is it is egomaniacal is what it is
now Don Lemon had something similar to
say on his show on I guess it was on
Friday he in what we're told is it was
an emotional segment
he said that Kevin Hart's apologies have
fallen flat and that heart needs to do
more outreach and he needs to become a
quote ally again the the arrogance who
are you to demand that someone be your
ally or that he engage in outreach and
make amends the apologies he was his
only sin here his his his crime which
was not really a crime but his crime was
that he said he said words seven or
eight years ago that I guess hurts some
people's feelings supposedly and I don't
I don't even buy that they really hurt
anyone's feelings at all because if
anyone's feelings were hurt they would
have expressed that seven or eight years
ago when he originally said it but when
you go digging something up when you go
looking for a fence and you find it you
can't claim to really be offended okay
when you go searching desperately
through Twitter or whatever or combing
through the archives of somebody's past
stand-up performances looking for
something offensive you're you obviously
want to find it and so when you find it
you can't say oh my gosh my feelings are
so hurt oh my tummy hurts that hurts so
much too
see no it doesn't hurt you're you're
excited you found what you were looking
for you went on a an expedition you went
on a hunt and you found the thing you
were looking for so you can't claim to
be a fit but if you were offended
considering the offense consisted only
of jokes only of words then all the
person needs to do is just a pile they
all I need to say is I'm sorry and that
should be enough but when you sit there
and say no you need to be an ally look
if somebody were to mock Christians
which of course people mock Christians
all the time especially in Hollywood and
never does it engender must much outrage
and you're not gonna see an emotional
segment from Don Lemon about you know
incendiary jokes that were made towards
Christians but if somebody does mock
Christians and and then apologizes for
it which again is rare that you would
get the apology but if you did then then
great I would be as a Christian I would
be appreciative of the apology I would
say thank you for apologizing I forgive
you okay let's move on you know what I
would never say to them I would never
say no you know what the apology isn't
good enough you need to be an ally of
the Christian community well why should
they be an ally who am I to demand that
someone else be an ally of mine now I
can ask that they refrain from mocking
or insulting me but I can't I can't say
that my acceptance of their apology is
contingent on them being an ally I have
no right to say that I have no right to
make that demand maybe they don't want
to be an ally of creep maybe they're not
Christians maybe they disagree with
Christians on a number of points but
they went overboard and expressing that
in disagreement and they went into the
realm of mockery and insults and so they
apologized but they still disagree so I
can't say no
what if you're really sorry then you're
going to agree with me about everything
and you're now going to be my Ally
it doesn't work that way and anyway
Ellen DeGeneres as I said is a lesbian
woman accepting the apology of a black
man and yet all of these liberals are
attacking her for it did did the rules
of identity politics get suspended again
I guess so now Don Lemon is a is a gay
black man so he might have enough
intersectional coinage to make these
criticisms according to the rules of
intersectionality Don Lemon as a gay
black man should be about on the same he
should be you know he should be on the
same level in the victim hierarchy as a
white gay woman I would think so so fine
as a as a as a victimized equal he can
say whatever he wants I guess according
to their rules but but everybody else I
mean all of these white straight
liberals who are on Twitter and you know
on social media complaining by their own
rules shouldn't they just shut up and
butt out now I happen to find it
absolutely insane and also morally
appalling to suggest that you only have
the right to to to be a part of a
certain conversation if you hit certain
demographic markers but that's what
liberals claim all the time that's their
rules and I could almost respect it
almost if they actually followed those
rules themselves but the problem is they
don't they suspend the rules whenever
they feel like it that's the main
problem with the intersectionality the
identity politics and everything is that
it's never applied equally and fairly
and consistently it just never is so
another
example of this would be according to
their rules a pro-abortion man should
never get into an argument with a
pro-life woman he should just cede the
point whenever a pro-life woman comes
along he should surrender because no
uterus no opinion right isn't that how
it's supposed to go
liberal men should only ever argue about
abortion with pro-life men but the
moment that a pro-life woman chimes in
he should just shut up and bow out those
are the rules that he tries to impose on
others those are the rules that he
should follow but he never does there's
that that video of and there are many
videos like this many cases like this
but there's the infamous video from a
few months ago of a pro-abortion man
essentially assaulting some pro-life
women who were holding signs as part of
a pro-life demonstration that sort of
thing should never happen
forget about assault he shouldn't even
be he shouldn't even be arguing with
them he should be bowing before them and
saying you know what I have no right to
have an opinion about this I mean it's
it's very convenient that when it comes
to the to the abortion issue the way
that liberals try to present it you know
they'll they'll say that Pro lifers are
men who are just trying to control
women's bodies and they just completely
overlook the millions and millions of
women who are Pro lifers in fact the the
dirty little secret here is that the
pro-life movement is led by women go to
the March for life sometime the March
for Life is gonna be in Washington at
the end of January this month go to the
March for Life I highly recommend it you
know you're gonna find you're gonna find
a whole bunch of women not just women
but young women you're gonna find a
whole bunch of women who are you know
teenage 20s 30s women who are leading
this movement
and according to the intersectional
rules according to the identity politics
rules
pro-choice men should have nothing to
say to them but it never works that way
didn't work that way with Ellen
DeGeneres and the Kevin Hart situation
it just never works that way they don't
apply the rules to themselves and you
know the main problem with that is when
you have a certain rule or a certain
principle and you don't apply it
consistently and you don't apply it to
yourself then you're never really going
to discover the problems with it that's
one of the reasons why I think
principled consistency is so important
it's because when you apply your
principles consistently and you apply
them to yourself then you're really
gonna get a look at your own principles
and if there are any flaws any problems
you're going to discover them but when
you just suspend those principles the
moment they wake up they become
inconvenient you're never going to see
the problems with them so if if
pro-choice men were to apply the
identity politics principles
consistently and then say to themselves
well you know what I'm not allowed to
say anything the moment that a pro-life
woman chimes in I have to just I have to
back down I can't I'm not allowed to
have an opinion but if they were to try
to live by that rule they would see you
know what this is insane actually why
shouldn't I be allowed to have an
opinion why should her demographics mean
that I'm excluded from having an opinion
and then maybe they would say oh you
know what okay so it it doesn't make any
sense when I apply it to myself so maybe
it doesn't make sense when I apply a
tell us maybe this whole thing is just
nonsense but if you don't apply it
consistently you'll never make that
discovery all right we'll leave it there
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed